actors are looking to renegotiate their
contracts in big budget movies scarlett
johansson the star of disney's latest
marvel movie black widow has filed a
lawsuit today in los angeles superior
court against disney traditional movie
contracts for a-list talent include
sizable upfront payments and a lucrative
back-end deal based mostly on box office
ticket sales but with more films going
straight to streaming platforms actors
are now looking for a piece of the
streaming profits the movie wouldn't
exist without actors and especially
actors of certain stature and with
certain names they drive people to those
theaters or they drive people to
download that subscription service and i
do believe that they should get a
portion of that paying stars a bigger
piece of digital sales would upend the
traditional pay structure for talent and
for some it could lead to tens of
millions of dollars in residual pay
money that agents and actors say is now
being left on the table here's a look at
how the scarlett johansson lawsuit
against disney could be a catalyst that
changes the way hollywood stars get paid
to understand what's at stake with
actors you have to understand how their
pay is tied to a film's distribution
cycle there are so many unique and
creative ways for actors and performers
to make additional compensation for
their participation in films natasha
matalana who's been representing actors
for over 15 years says depending on the
contract back-end bonuses in the long
run can be more lucrative for actors
than an upfront payment some of that
compensation is creatively carved out by
way of calling it a production fee or a
marketing fee or back end points those
bonuses are tied to how well the film
does at each point of the distribution
cycle traditionally that cycle looks
like this feature films start their
journey with a theatrical release that
can last anywhere from a few weeks to a
few months depending on how well it does
in the box office at this stage talent
contracts for actors can include a cut
of the opening box office sales after
it's run in the theaters a film would
then make its way onto dvd or
pay-per-view depending on their contract
an actor might make a cut of that as
well about six months after that the
title would become available on
streaming services like disney plus or
hulu this gives talent another
opportunity to cash in this time for
licensing deals with various streaming
content providers eventually if a film
was well received it could also end up
syndicated on television syndicated
films can continue to make money for
studios and talent as long as the
broadcaster continues to license and air
the film so that's what it looked like
before here's what it's starting to look
like today studios like disney and
warner media are releasing films both in
theaters for cinema goers and online for
the at-home audience at the same time
viewers who watch in theaters pay the
normal price per ticket for admission
and those who watch at home might pay
twice once for a monthly subscription
and depending on the streaming service
again with a surcharge for early access
to the film unlike box office retail dvd
and licensing streaming surcharges and
subscription fees are usually not split
with the talent depending on the actors
contract they may still retain their
backend residuals for things like dvd
sales foreign sales and pay-per-views
but those have always been far less
lucrative compared to box office bonuses
with direct-to-streaming studios have
found a promising solution for poor box
office sales actors and agents argue
that same-day streaming is in direct
competition with a theatrical release
and they're taking a huge loss in back
end residuals
well disney says they made about 60
million dollars just from the digital
side of that when they release black
widow dan gallagher who's been following
the rise in popularity of streaming
platforms for the wall street journal
says disney stockholders really wanted
to see them invest in the streaming
future when you put something out like
black widow where people have a choice
on the day of there's always going to be
some number that choose that convenience
so it really can't help but cannibalize
some of that theatrical return at least
2 million households purchase the 30
early access stream on the film's
opening weekend johansen's lawsuit
argues that her contract with disney's
marvel entertainment guaranteed an
exclusive theatrical release and her
salary was tied to the box office
performance of the film however the film
was released in theaters and on disney
plus at the same time the decision that
a person familiar with the details of
her contract said would cost her more
than 50 million dollars disney said it
fully comply with johansen's contract
and that the release of black widow on
disney plus has significantly enhanced
the actors ability to earn additional
compensation digital film releases are
happening more and more according to
real good straight to video on demand
movie premieres have more than tripled
in q4 year over year in 2020 228 film
titles went straight to subscription
videos on demand the pandemic played a
large part in accelerating the shift to
premiering films online but that option
was already in motion before theaters
began to close i definitely think that
this is a path that perhaps we were
always headed down
i just think that it might have been a
couple of years down the road and now
because of covet it made it go fast so
what are contracts going to look like
moving forward matalana says that actors
will need to negotiate contracts that
focus far less on box office ticket
sales and a-list actors will likely try
to negotiate a cut of any surcharge fees
for early access to their new films
actors with enough star power may even
be entitled to revenue from new
subscribers during a film's release 2020
was a very ideal environment for
streaming because people didn't have a
lot of options in a world where people
have more entertainment options it's
going to normalize to something i think
bigger than it was prior to the pandemic
streaming new movies at home is
convenient for viewers and for streaming
platforms very profitable agents and
actors know this and experts say that
moving forward they'll start looking for
new and creative ways to negotiate their
way into contracts that cut themselves
in on the streaming profits